those of us who really yearn for a
return to first principles the natural
law the Constitution the government that
only has powers that we have expressly
consented that it may have are
frustrated with the choice between
Barack Obama in and Mitt Romney hi I'm
Matt Welch for recent TV I'm at Freedom
Fest in Las Vegas and I am tickled to be
joined with our good old friend Judge
Andrew Napolitano thank you for joining
us judge pleasure to be here Matt I'm
talking to you not long after the
Supreme Court Obamacare decision that
John Roberts to step is it a incredibly
wild loss for Liberty are you more
optimistic in the Randy Barnett sense of
maybe you know we won the long game and
lost a short one word I am NOT
optimistic I think the opinion was the
jurisprudential equivalent of passing a
camel for the eye of a needle I think
that it's totally unprecedented out of
the blue contrary to prevailing
standards of interpreting the
Constitution and contrary to everything
all the lawyers who argued before the
Supreme Court said I can't get in the
Chief Justice's had any more than
anybody else can only he could tell us
why he had this sudden change of mind
what he succeeded in doing was granting
Congress power on a platter that
Congress never even realized it had so
Congress cannot say to you under the
Commerce Clause you may not wear a blue
tie but Congress can find you for
wearing the tie as long as it refers to
the fine as a tax that is a power
without limitation Congress can now
regulate any private behavior at once as
long as the penalty for not complying
with Congress's regulation is a
financial penalty and as long as you
call that financial penalty attacks now
the Randy Barnett counter-argument is
that well this was so narrowly tailored
and tortured that this precedent really
basically only applies to this decision
the statutes proponents denounced
denounced the idea that it was a tax we
live in a society where judges and
justices resolve disputes between
parties
they don't come from out of the blue and
create an entire new structure in an
effort to satisfy the parties they rule
on the basis of the Constitution and the
law so to call something attacks that no
one in the case referred to as a tax is
a gross form of judicial activism in
this case enhancing the power of the
federal government which by definition
assaults the power of the states and
saps personal freedom this is a 5-4
decision that's been plenty of them the
court has been pretty split along 54 ish
lines depending on how you look at it
this is the oddest if I that we have
seen in modern times in a major decision
but people who get excited about
partisan politics more than let's say
you or I get excited about partisan
politics will point to a presidential
election and say hey look you know on
your grade much lamented freedom watch
program you're always talking about how
the Republican Party very rarely can be
trusted on issues that we care about in
terms of fiscal discipline and and and
just respecting individual freedom but
they'll say hey look in a 5-4 universe
the president matters so you've got to
back the one who isn't Barack Obama in
this case because he might nominate
three does this type of argumentation
move you yes it moves me and it
frustrates me because I am deep
ideologically and personally in the camp
of Ron Paul and gary johnson I realize
they're not running together but just to
for the sake of the folks watching us to
place myself and I have articulated on
air and will say again what I think is
demonstrable Mitt Romney's views are
closer to Barack Obama's than they are
to Ron Paul's or Thomas Jefferson's I
think that's demonstrable I don't think
there's any spin in that and I think
that could easily be demonstrated so
those of us who really yearn for a
return to first principles the natural
law the Constitution a government that
only has powers that we have expressly
consented that it may have are
frustrated with the choice between
Barack Obama in
Mitt Romney and it's a difficult choice
to make does one vote for Gary Johnson
as a way of demonstrating there's a huge
base of libertarians out there and even
though you're going to be President
Governor Romney we're going to be
watching you or does one vote for Mitt
Romney because he's the lesser of two
evils and is not likely to give US
Supreme Court appointments of the nature
that Barack Obama has I myself have not
yet resolved this I work with some
wonderful people on Sixth Avenue on
forty-seventh Street in New York City
called Fox and most of my colleagues
believe and I share this view the Barack
Obama is arguably the president most
dangerous to human freedoms it's Abraham
Lincoln so there's a great groundswell
amongst libertarians to toss some
support to to Mitt Romney so that we
never have to live in fear of what
Barack Obama might do by executive order
or decree after all he's killed
Americans on his own and claimed he has
the right to do this this is an
extremely dangerous person but the short
answer to your question is yes I'd
rather have Mitt Romney choose a Supreme
Court nominee than Barack Obama what's
next for the judge what are you working
on new books new activities my next book
which comes out after election day is a
history of and an assault on the
Progressive Era and the title is
Theodore and Woodrow how a Republican
and a Democratic president destroyed the
Constitution my columnas has taken off
its and a lot of nice venues the reason
com it's at reason.com is in the
washington times and I enjoy it very
much a lot of my Fox colleagues have
sort of rediscovered Judge Napolitano
and I'm some days I'm actually on air
more than I used to be in the in the
happy freedom watch days so it's a busy
happy life of addressing these issues in
a meaningful way and still being the
night watchman of the government that
will steal your property and your
freedom if you let it that's great thank
you so much judge appreciate it as your
mat for recent TV i'm at well